[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID EDWARDS: I'm really
delighted to be here
and hope we can have a
dialogue after I speak
a little bit about my book.
So yeah, far from
scaring you, I think
I want to reassure you initially
that creating is really
something that we all do
every day of our lives.
It's one of the most fundamental
biological processes.
And to frame that, it's pretty
clear that there's hardly
a condition in the
course of your day
that you encounter that's
fully predictable or predicted.
You encounter it, and you act
in a fundamentally creative way.
You go right, or you go left.
And that may be a
trivial creative act
or a consequential creative
act, but in any case
it matters to you in the moment
that you do it or you wouldn't
have done it.
Occasionally, those creative
acts lead to creative things,
and those created
things may be anything
from a well-articulated
sentence, to a pirouette,
to a book.
And those things matter to
you when you create them,
or you wouldn't create them.
Now, it has turned out
to be in our interest
to create not only
for ourselves things
that matter, but also
things that matter
for many of those around us.
The clan and the well
being of the clan
tends to correlate with our
own personal well-being.
And therefore, over
time, our biology
has pushed us to think
about creating things
that matter not just
to ourselves right now,
but to others, and for a
fairly long period of time.
And if you look over the
course of human history
at created things, whether
it's an equation or a wheel,
these things have
tended to involve,
of course, collaboration,
discussion,
figuring out what matters to the
clan, and pooling of resources.
And when we finally
made something,
we've tended to make
it to last not just
for the moment
when we created it,
but for some relatively
long period of time.
And therefore, villages,
and pyramids, and shoes
tended for most of history
to last quite a long time.
Fast forward to
where we are today.
And we're in a
moment that in a way
is the pinnacle achievement
of human creativity.
And if you read Steven
Pinker's recent book, clearly
by most indicators,
the human condition
is better off today
by human creativity
than it ever has been.
But one of the
uniquenesses of our moment
is that the created
things that surround us
are remarkably short-lived.
And the reason for
that is multiple.
Firstly, among the things that
we have a limited supply of
is time.
And therefore in
all of history, when
we have had a chance to
create something tomorrow
versus creating something
that matters to us the day
after tomorrow, we sort
of focus on tomorrow.
Time matters.
And over the last 300
years, and maybe especially
over the last 30 years, the
power of science and technology
has made it possible to
create things of mass utility
really rapidly.
And it's led to this increasing
focus on creating things
over a really short
period of time,
and that's skewed our
perception of what
creativity is, and really led
me to the writing of this book.
It's also created, of course,
the situation highlighted
by the United Nations
and their identification
of the 17 sustainable
development
goals, of a world that is in
risk of no sustainability.
And therefore, many
today are focusing
whether it's on
feeding the planet,
or saving life in the
sea, or preserving
the environment in some
way on creating over
a long period of time.
Now, I'd like to just talk for
a little bit about creating
and this concept of learning.
If you think about the sort of
canonical creator environment,
you probably think about
the scientific lab,
which is indeed responsible
for much of the created
world around us today.
And if you think about what
happens in a scientific lab,
you probably have in mind
the scientific method.
And indeed, the
scientific method
is one of the things that
goes on in a science lab.
We tend to focus on phenomena
whose laws we understand.
We frame those
phenomena in conditions
that are really well-specified.
And we apply the
scientific method,
and we observe, and deduce,
and we make discoveries.
However, in pioneering
work in science,
and engineering,
and other domains,
we tend to have either
not perfect understanding
of the phenomena nor perfect
understanding of the conditions
that frame them.
And as much as analysis
and deduction matters
in the science lab, actually,
intuition and imagination
matters, too.
And therefore, the scientific
process in science labs,
or in engineering
labs, or in labs
generally, is a combination of
the classical scientific method
and what I call an
artistic method.
It blends this
induction, deduction,
comfort with uncertainty, and
ability to frame a problem
and move on into
a single process
that over the last
10 or 15 years
I've been talking about
as an art science process.
Now, if you take the
metaphor of the science lab
and you apply it to your
lives here at Google
or to your personal lives,
this balance of art and science
still holds, and there's
probably a lot more art
that is involved in science.
And you can take any example.
An example, for example,
of losing your watch,
you make a hypothesis that
your watch is under your bed.
You then test your hypothesis
by looking for your watch,
and you make a discovery,
and so on, and so forth.
And that's generally how we
encounter opportunity and need
in our lives, and by this
balance of art and science.
Now, in my book, I
talk about this notion
of an aesthetic
work or aesthetics.
And a lot of thinking over
the last century particularly
around aesthetics as
being closely coupled
with a kind of
mindful way of living.
And if you look at the most
mindful of experiments,
the works that come
from those, whether it's
a scientific
article or a relief,
can be thought of
as aesthetic works,
so I'd like to talk about
aesthetic works just
for a little bit.
If you look over the
course of history
at things that we've made
through experimental processes,
whether they're books,
or plays, or reliefs,
they have generally
invited a reaction
from the public of
observation and learning.
And that has led
to how we structure
our universities,
our museums, and even
our companies and stores.
If you look, however,
at the last 30
years or so at cultural works
and works of technology,
indeed, as you produce
here at Google,
they invite a very different
kind of public experience.
This here is an image from
Olafur Eliasson's 2004 weather
project at the Tate Modern.
A kind of sun was created
in the Tate Modern,
and people were
invited to observe.
And nobody had any idea
how people would observe.
And they actually ended
up laying on their backs,
and they ended up
making formations.
There's a whole story about how
the weather project was lived.
But they became part
of the cultural work.
And that's indeed what's
happened in technology,
in media, if you
look at something
like a smartphone, which
invites me to engage,
and my engagement changes
the phone in a certain way,
just as Google is changed
by me using Google.
And so there's this
increasing participation
of the public with
the creator, and we're
all kind of creating together.
And I say all of
that just to say
that the notion of
learning, indeed, even
of commerce as being one of
a producer and a consumer,
is going away.
And it actually has
a radical impact
on how we think about learning
at Harvard University,
and ultimately probably
doing business.
And so I've been focused
over the last 15 years
on the synonymous nature
of learning about tomorrow
and creating tomorrow,
and particularly focusing
on, among other
things, little kids.
My book begins with a
story about a little kid.
If you think about
the ultimate pioneers,
they are little kids, right?
They're encountering conditions
that are radically new
and they are learning
at an amazing rate.
And if all is particularly
supportive, they're having fun.
And so this is something that
I come back to very frequently.
They're being motivated not
for a commercial purpose
or for making a
name for themselves,
but they're just
fascinated, super curious,
and they're learning.
Now, particularly
in my book, I focus
on pioneers,
pioneering creators who
are creating over a very
long period of time,
and actually in quite risky
and uncertain conditions.
And I focus on the emotive
and cognitive dimensions
that lead to not only successful
pioneering creating, but also
deep pleasure.
And to give you just
a little insight,
one of the creators
who I spent time with,
David Doubilet, who is one of
the great marine photographers
of our time, and
invented the split screen
or the split lens
for photographing
above and below water.
And I was talking to
David about the qualities
important in a buddy in
diving deep into the ocean.
And just to point
out, as I'll mention
more here in the last part
of my talk, when we pioneer,
we tend to pioneer
best not alone.
Now, we're not clearly
not in a village,
but we tend to have
a team, a buddy who's
thinking of our interest, and
we are thinking of her interest,
and that tends to maximize
or optimize our survival.
And it's obviously true
in diving in the ocean.
I asked David, well, what are
the qualities that matter most
to you?
And he said, well, the
second-most important quality,
which interesting that
he started with that,
was that they be kind.
There's nothing worse
than diving with somebody
and risking your life
with somebody who's
just fundamentally not kind.
And so I said, well, what's the
first most important quality?
And he said, well, they need
to be passionately curious.
And so obviously at a
frontier, if you're not
waking up and motivated to
explore, then nobody will be,
right?
So this passionate
curiosity, empathy, these
are the kinds of emotive
and cognitive dimensions
that I focus on in the book.
And I look at creators
like Ferran Adria,
the chef of El Bulli,
which closed down in 2011,
arguably the greatest
chef living today.
And I look at their creative
process from great scientists
living today to great
inventors to artists,
and I show that all of them
follow a very similar process.
They may all do really
well economically.
They may create amazingly
successful companies
or amazingly successful
music theater.
And yet, what's driving them
is something else, actually,
and it's related to the
reward system of our brains.
And you are all probably
aware, but just to remind you,
there are three fundamental
processes that motivate us
through the reward system.
One is a wanting process, one
is a reinforcement learning
process, and one is
a liking process.
And an illustration
of this very simply
would be "Anna Karenina."
Let's say I'm told
to for my class
or for some other
reason want to read
Leo Tolstoy's "Anna Karenina."
There's some pleasure,
actually, in wanting anything.
And particularly wanting
to read "Anna Karenina,"
I read it, so there's this
reinforcement learning.
I begin to like "Anna Karenina."
And finally, having
finished the book,
I really like it so much
that I talk to my wife
about "Anna Karenina,"
and we exchange ideas.
And when I go to read my
next book of Leo Tolstoy,
"War and Peace," I
have been informed
through that conversation
with my wife.
And that kind of
cycle of how we learn
is really the cycle
of how we create.
And so in Ferran Adria's
case, from the ideating,
to the experimenting, to the
serving of an amazing dish.
This cycle in all
of the creator lives
that I describe is fundamental
not only to learning,
the kinds of dimensions
that I mentioned,
the empathy, the passion,
and others that I'll
mention in just a minute.
But also creating value that
they bring to the public,
there's a conversation much like
what happens with the internet.
And everyone learns,
and then they go back.
And not only is that formative
for the creative thing,
this new thing that the
world has never seen before,
which goes through this cycle of
communication with the public,
but it's actually
deeply pleasurable.
So in my book, I highlight
these emotive and cognitive
dimensions, which
are pretty contrasted
to the emotive and
cognitive dimensions
that we tend to
celebrate in culture
and maybe inculcate in our
businesses and our business
schools.
And so it's clear that in
the success of a Google
or the success of even my
book, both sets of qualities
are important.
There are times
when we're at battle
and there are times
where we are discovering.
And the qualities that lead
to the successful warrior
are pretty defiantly
not the qualities that
lead to the successful pioneer.
And one of the challenges
in writing a book
or bringing great value to the
world in a company like Google
is, how do you
balance these two?
In my book, I am focusing mostly
on this patch of blue and red,
and the cycle of creating that
allows for these qualities
to be learned, and relearned,
and ultimately shared.
Now, if I asked you, what are
the qualities in the neighbors
you'd like to live with?
I can imagine which--
sorry, I hope I
can imagine which
set of qualities they are.
And one of the
points in my book is
while we are interested today
obviously in creating things
that matter to many over a
very long period of time,
this future that we're all
looking for really starts
today, right?
And it's as much as it
relates to this thing
that you're mattering, it
relates even more fundamentally
to how you create
this thing, right?
And so this way of living,
passionate curiosity, empathy,
intuition, innocence,
humility, all of which
I describe more
fundamentally in the book,
is critical, I believe, to
introduce into our schools,
into our companies,
and into culture.
And indeed in my book, I talk
about how that's happening.
So the last part of
my book emphasizes
the grassroots creator
movement, which
I identify as beginning
around the time
of the first tweet, the first
Maker Faire, "Make Magazine."
Over the last 10, 15 years as
you've thrived here at Google,
the world has radically
changed, as we all know.
But one of the things
that's most striking to me
is that over a short period
of time, much of the planet
has now placed itself in
a position of creatively
expressing itself in a way
that never happened before,
and expressing itself
in ways that endure.
Much of this creation
may be viewed
by many as trivial, or not
interesting, or even profoundly
irritating.
But it is fundamentally,
and in many cases,
not to make money, not to make
a name, although that happens,
but to express oneself
and express an experience
that one has had.
That aesthetic
creation is, I think,
fundamental to creating
the world that we all
wish to live in.
And indeed, it's
starting to restructure
how we run companies,
the kinds of environments
that companies are
thriving in, and it's quite
reflected by your own campus.
And so I've been very involved.
I've opened a
restaurant in Cambridge
and have my students
making things.
And so I'm really interested
in this grassroots creative
movement.
And one of the things that
fascinates me and I talk about
in the book is that we're
seeing this self-association
that creators,
grassroots creators make.
And these happen
online, obviously,
but they also happen in
physical environments.
And these could be Habitat for
Humanity kinds of gathering,
or they could be weekend
food-making gatherings.
These could happen in classes,
lots of maker activities.
But these are often
self-associations
of creators who want to create
together, maybe write fiction
together.
And they come together
really very frequently
for the pleasure of
creating together.
And they learn, as I write in
the book, these same qualities,
these aesthetic dimensions
of creating that are not
only fundamental to
creating over a very
long period of time,
but having fun,
and personal self-satisfaction.
So I'm going to end
really quickly here
by talking about two
innovation activities
that I've been very engaged
with over these 15 years
as I've been learning myself
and creating environments that
foster this kind of learning.
And one of these relates
to my work in Africa
in the early 2000s.
I was one of the first Gates
Grand Challenge grantees,
and was focused on inhaled
vaccines and antibiotics
for tuberculosis, and set up a
not-for-profit in South Africa.
And I became struck
by the middle 2000s,
there was relative
affluence coming to Africa
by these mounds of trash
that were growing outside
of the cities, and this sort
of importation of diseases
that we thought, until
then were fundamentally
developed world diseases,
like cardiac, and depression,
and other kinds of illnesses.
And shifted my work
for many other reasons
to food, and ultimately
for a significant amount
of my creative time
to food packaging.
And I came up with this
idea that, well, we really
should make packaging like
nature makes packaging,
and the ultimate water
bottle is the coconut,
and so I began to reflect
on how that would be done.
Now, this was for
many years curated
in a cultural context where
we did an exhibition in Paris
at the Laboratoire,
this cultural center
that I opened in 2007, and
invited the public to eat water
bottles.
And for two or three years,
this kind of wikifood
was a cultural
experiment, and we set up
an underground
restaurant in Paris.
And this led to a
company eventually,
and to products that sell
particularly on the East Coast,
and ultimately to this product
of which I have some here,
which you can now make
any fruit in the form--
or any food, really,
in the form of grapes.
And the product that
is now launched,
and that you can
taste are fruit.
Kids are not eating fruit
anymore because the trend is
going down because fruit
is complicated to eat,
and parents are
concerned about skins.
But you can remake fruit
with these edible packages,
if you will, or skins.
And this work now through
a number of collaborators
is moving to an
effort in Africa,
particularly Sierra Leone,
to develop local food forms
that are environmentally
sustainable
and that are highly
vectorized by micronutrients.
So what began as
an idea in Africa
moved through a
cultural environment
for a time that might
have been indeterminate.
It certainly was in the process.
Became a company, a
venture-backed company,
and is now coming back to
Africa all through a process
that kind of needed to have this
open-ended and driving force
that was other than pure
commercial interest.
Now, I'll just finish
by saying that I've also
been interested since
my first company related
to inhaled insulin and
delivering health and wellness
through the air, and have become
fascinated since the Nobel
Prize in 2004 with the
revolution happening
in olfactory biology.
The largest subclass
of the human genome
is a factory receptor subclass.
Olfactory receptors are
not just in your nose.
They're throughout your body.
And so there's this
amazing conversation that's
going on sensorially inside
of you that we understand now
is fundamentally
related to olfaction,
and clearly plays a major
role in metabolic health
and neurologic health.
And getting that
right, we believe,
is partly related
to righting some
of the metabolic and
neurologic dysfunction that's
happened here over the
last 30 or 40 years.
And so we've developed this
platform for digitizing scent,
and begun to work and
collaborate with Questlove,
and thinking about
synesthesia, and how
these kinds of experiences
can improve well-being
and experience even of
music, and ultimately come
into work environments
looking how sensory design can
improve the workspace.
And finally, we're coming out
with our first real mass market
product here this
year, which I can
share with you, which
is a way of creating
flavor images, either
autonomously or over any food.
You can color any food
with a flavor of chocolate,
or popcorn, or rum.
And then in consuming
that food, your brain
tells you that that's
just what I've had.
And so it's a really
interesting way
to address some of the
food addiction issues
that we're dealing with today.
So once again, this project
began blue sky, actually,
with some of my
students developed
in a cultural environment
for a long period of time,
and finally, through
commercial forces,
is moving into the marketplace.
So I'd like to
just end by saying
that these sorts of culture
lab environments that
began to show up in
Europe in the middle 2000s
are now increasingly showing
up in companies like yours.
I view what I know of Google,
in part, as a culture lab.
We moved the Laboratoire
Culture Lab to Cambridge in 2014
and began the World
Frontiers Forum.
And the World Frontiers
Forum is a gathering
of leaders from
around the world.
We bring them to experience
15 frontiers of tomorrow
from contemporary
art to biology,
a significant collaboration
with the United Nations,
and we try to hatch every year
a project that can scale rapidly
in the developing world
and address one or more
of the sustainable
development challenges.
And so this gets back
to this notion of,
how do you capture the energy of
the grassroots creator movement
and help guide it
towards sustainability
of the human condition in the
long time that has always been
our biological self-interest?
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm not sure how we do
questions and answers,
but I'd really love
to talk with you.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
what your thoughts are
if you've looked
at this difference
in the creative space
between people who
are kind of, like,
the visionaries,
and how this idea, like, oh,
this product would be really
cool, and then they
assemble a team of people
to get that done,
versus the creatives who
are more on the side of the
actual people who are building
the products, and
creating the technologies,
and kind of like what the
different qualities of people
on those different sides
of the equation are.
DAVID EDWARDS: Yeah, absolutely.
And I find it always helpful--
so the question for those of
you who didn't hear that clearly
is, how do you
combine the visionary
with the creatives who are
bringing vision to practice?
And I think implicitly,
you're suggesting
that as I kind of did,
that there are really
different qualities that lead to
success here and success here.
And often, those cultures
don't really mix very well.
And, of course, this has
been true throughout history.
And I think today in
the highly specialized
world that we live in, and the
way we educate and organize
ourselves, the barriers between
those two cultures are greater.
I think that very successful
cultural innovation
environments-- and I view
Silicon Valley would be
an example of such
an environment,
Boston maybe for biotech,
New York maybe for Broadway
theater--
tend to create subcultures.
And I think that generally,
you have a learning culture,
where visionaries
often thrive, you
have an experimental culture
where people can fail and get
paid for it, actually, and
you have an environment where
people produce.
And any of those are
sort of relatively easy,
and you find them in
many, many places.
It's very hard, however,
to create a culture
where ideas and people
move between them
and where there's a trust
that allows that to happen.
And that is the pixie
dust of creating tomorrow.
And, again, it's something that
I talk more about in the book.
I think that to be a little bit
more concrete, partly because
of the nature of the world
that we are living in today,
and frankly, the risky
nature of the world
we're living in today
probably has a lot more
to do with our
evolutionary conditions
than the world of big
offices and sure paychecks.
We can thrive less
well with the luxury
of considering myself
a pure visionary,
or considering myself
a pure applied creator.
And we're needing all of
us to tolerate and thrive
in the conditions of
pioneering vision,
as well as be engaged in
the complexity of sharing
that vision with others
and learning from others.
So the ivory tower is under--
I don't know if it
ever really existed,
but it's very hard
to rationalize today.
And I think honestly, it's
very hard to be a visionary
and not be engaged
in what you're
describing as that creative
exchange with the public.
It used to be we understood
better what people needed.
And I think increasingly, we
need everyone to tell us that.
So I'm hopeful that those two
cultures are coming together.
And in any case, I
think environments
need to do a lot to just
help both sides communicate.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I agree with you.
There's a lot of
exciting empowerment
and personal creativity.
But at the same time,
I see increasing trends
toward rewarding short-term
gains, shorter and shorter
product life cycles,
which is where
we get these piles
of trash, and so on.
So how do we start to shift
towards our culture valuing
longer-term contributions?
That seems like a real
challenge to this.
DAVID EDWARDS: Yeah, absolutely.
And as was true in the
Italian Renaissance, any sort
of Renaissance period,
on the one hand,
we like to talk about the
heroes of the Renaissance.
But it was a very tough
time to be living.
Everything was kind of caving,
and all of the institutions
were pointing us in
the wrong direction,
and that's even more
profoundly true today.
And so it's hard to look at
anything almost in the media,
if nowhere else, and not realize
that the qualities that I'm
highlighting that I believe
are really critical to creating
a world we all want to live
in are not very frequently
the qualities that are being
propagated in our institutions.
I think one of the things
that I'm saying for sure
is that those qualities
of short-termism
are not sustainable.
And so I'm personally less
interested in spending
my energy in figuring out,
how do I wake people up to--
and there are a lot of
people who are awakened.
And I think that in the
spirit of the pioneer,
I prefer to be with
those pioneers making
tomorrow, and just assuming that
the unsustainable activity here
well will stop at some point.
AUDIENCE: I had a
similar question
to build on his about
short-term thinking
and long-term thinking.
We have many
institutions, including
the government in the US,
where you elect officials
every four years.
Companies like Google, you have
annual or quarterly performance
reviews and things like that.
You have to show some
progress towards a goal.
How do you bridge that
gap between needing
to show some short-term
progress, short-term goals
and solving long-term problems,
like asteroids hitting Earth 20
years from now, 50 years?
DAVID EDWARDS: So
great question.
And as I also write
about in the book,
and maybe did not
emphasize enough here,
I don't believe personally
that the value that a Harvard
University brings to
the world or a Google
brings to the world,
both institutions being
under extreme
pressure to deliver
value today, and this semester,
or this quarter and both,
however, being highly
invested in the future of 30
years from now.
So there's the big question,
which is what you just asked.
Well, how do you
balance the fact
that we do have students
showing up this semester?
They really do need
to take a class.
And maybe it's true that we
need to rethink education
completely.
But meanwhile,
you've got students
you've got to teach
today, and you
can't tell them what we're
figuring it out, right?
And so that's kind of the issue.
So I think what de
facto is happening,
and it explains my role
at Harvard University,
and I think from my
understanding of Google
and a lot of the California
technology scene,
enlightened leadership
that is giving space
to whether it's
giving all of you
time to think out of the box or
letting you create a company,
and move off
campus, and creating
these experimental
sandboxes where
we can dream about the future.
And that itself is
relatively simple.
What's difficult,
actually, is how
to create that sandbox
where not only do you go off
and think long-term, but what
you do matters to me back here.
So that's the bigger issue
is, how do I stay in touch
and not lose sight of you?
Why do I keep caring?
And that is really an
enlightened leadership issue.
And I think, getting
back to this point
that I tried to make
earlier, the good thing
about where we're
at right now is
that it's so urgent
that we pay attention
to the longer-term
future that we just
can't afford to send you off
to think about the future,
and then forget about you.
And so I think that
there's clearly
an awakening happening
today that I am hopeful
will lead to more of that.
But it is a complicated
balance that I think all of us
in a way strike in our lives.
And if you think
back, childhood--
I have kids now, 15, 17, and
19, and I've learned so much
from them, and I still do.
But if you think back
on the qualities that
made you survive
adolescence, where
you needed at the same
time to be profoundly
in the moment and local,
and at the same time,
you had to think, well, I'm
going to college, and I--
[MUMBLING]
And you had to think, and
you were in this sort of--
that's really what
life is about, right?
And I think that there's been
too much now for too long where
we kind of assume
that, well, that ended,
and then you kind
of, and then this.
We need to balance all
those things, for sure.
AUDIENCE: I just want
to hear your thoughts
on AI and creativity.
I think with artificial
intelligence today,
we tend to see more
and more of things
that we are already thinking
and that other people were
thinking.
But how you go outside
the box and how you
see AI playing a role in that.
DAVID EDWARDS: Yeah.
Well, again, this is
another big, big question,
and I think my innocence will
help simplify the answer.
So let me just first say that
one of the things I read about
in the book and
that I experience
every semester
with my students is
this first day
where I'm presenting
the concept of the class.
You got to create something
that matters, and in one year.
And I write about
this in the book.
A student asks this question,
and this gets asked every year
in one form or another.
What if I don't have an idea?
And the complement to that
is the student who says,
I got an idea, and the
next thing, goes like,
but I found it online.
Like, this is out there already.
And my point to both of those
young people is the same.
That if you-- we're getting
to artificial intelligence.
I just want to finish
this little thought.
That I think what makes you
matter now more than me,
in a certain way, is that
you own your experience,
and I don't.
And that experience tells
you something about now
and about the needs
and opportunities
now that only you know.
And if from that, you
observe, you're mindful enough
to kind of just notice, and
you have an idea, a want,
that is coming from
this intuition,
a lot of observations you
couldn't even articulate.
And so yeah, a wheel, I
want to create a wheel.
And then you say,
well, my god, people
have created wheels
for a long time.
But I will say to
you, but forget
about what people have created.
Why the hell did
you say a wheel?
What does that mean for you?
And as you dig into
it, and you dig
into that big bank of
knowledge, which is intuition,
you will have created
something unique, your wheel.
So I say all of
that to say that I
think two things about
artificial intelligence
from my really
distant perspective.
One, the obvious thing that
really what's happening
is the natural and artificial
are kind of merging,
and we're all--
it's kind of going to be
difficult to really separate
between the two,
and it already is.
The whole notion
of consciousness
as being something that's
biological is crazy.
It's clearly distributed.
And so clearly, there's
this merger going on.
Not fairly, so a
big issue and that
is learning, learning to
adapt to this [INAUDIBLE]
we don't all learn, so
that's a huge issue.
I think the second
thing-- and this
gets to thriving humanity
in the long term.
I think that my intuition is
that what is happening here
with the advance of
artificial intelligence
is what makes us
human, most human?
Which is not
probably the calculus
that I learned when I was,
like, 20 years of age.
But it's actually that intuitive
bank of knowledge of my moment.
I own that.
And I own that in a way that
no computer, however smart,
who wasn't there, can know.
And so being able to mine that.
And as you know, as we're
advancing so rapidly
towards this future of
artificial intelligence
and present, we're
discovering that biology
is like a black hole, in
terms of the complexity
and sophistication.
And so my guess is that
there will be a coexistence,
again, not without pain.
And I think there
are a lot of issues,
as I say, related to equity
and how we manage this.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying really
hard to resist the temptation
to just meander
and ramble, so I'm
going to try to make this
as short as I possibly can.
DAVID EDWARDS: I'm
happy with meandering.
AUDIENCE: But it sort
of piggybacks off
of Tom's comment, and I don't
know your name, but the comment
you had after, and
something you said
about the Italian Renaissance.
I recently read the new
biography of Leonardo da Vinci.
And one of the things
that struck me was--
and this is according
to the author--
how often that he had a
patron who just gave him
so much leeway,
and so much time,
and then he spent the time
just doing whatever he wanted,
or moving on, and
procrastinating.
So he left angry patron
after angry patron.
But that freedom that he
had to do whatever he want
led to two or three
amazing masterpieces
and a lot of half-finished
stuff, a lot of exploration.
And as the other two
commenters alluded to, now,
and as you said, now,
we're so goal-oriented,
and so quarterly goal,
yearly goal-focused
that I know you said in
response to both of those
that the policy is
not, like, I guess
the focus of what you're
thinking on with this.
But it does seem like
a natural next step
to seeing, how can we unlock
more potential from people?
There are a lot of
creative people.
How do we unlock it?
DAVID EDWARDS: Yeah.
Can I respond to that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID EDWARDS: OK, cool.
I read this, so in fact, I go
more into this in the book.
Take Leonardo.
As you say, the patron,
or what I call activator,
played a big role.
Patrons look different today.
It's true, we have
the Larry Pages,
and we have the Bill Gates.
But the radical change in
patronage, if you will,
is that it's gone
grassroots, so there's
a kind of-- but
activators are everywhere,
but the activators matter.
And the second thing is this
what I call cultural lab,
like in Florence.
He was super lucky to
have been born in Florence
when he was born
in Florence, right?
So there's all this
stuff going on,
and experimentation
was being invited.
And there was a
culture that could
look at the experiment of the
Duomo and call it beautiful.
And so there was this ability
to see the new as potentially
being very beautiful.
And so it invited.
So there was a
culture that mattered.
And finally, Leonardo
would be a real model
of the kind of dimensions
that I'm referring to.
And so we do need
this environment
that includes people willing to
bet on you, and in particular,
bet on your ability to
realize a dream that
matters to more than you.
We do need you to be surrounded
by those who can appreciate it,
and we do
fundamentally need you.
So I think that while, again,
getting back to the earlier
point, we are, and you
are here at Google,
and I am, to the extent
that I am at Harvard,
in environments
where you see a lot
of the success of the last 20,
30, and maybe more years kind
of an intertial wave that we're
a part of that may be a little
bit overwhelming, particularly
if we try to move away from it.
So we're just [? kind of ?]
getting [? carried ?] along.
AUDIENCE: Very much so.
DAVID EDWARDS: But
fortunately, that
is not the whole of human
experience right now.
And I think that
all I can say, which
is how I manage my relationship
with Harvard University.
I'm super delighted and
lucky that Harvard still
calls me one of their
faculty members.
But I spend a lot of time
away, and I spent a lot of time
in my own space.
And I think that
depending upon who
you are and the kind of
pioneering you want to do,
an enlightened organization,
I'm sure Google should give you
that space.
Now, it's just important
to understand that Leonardo
led a really risky life.
He was not happy
a lot of the time,
and he didn't feel he
was getting credit.
He had a lot of stuff.
And so being out alone,
you have to realize
that hanging by
your fingernails,
it looks great when you then
got to the top of Mount Everest,
but you're mostly
hanging from fingernails,
and you've got to--
I personally feel that we
need to all do more of that.
So that was a rambling response
to your rambling question.
AUDIENCE: Well I have a very
directed short follow, I guess.
DAVID EDWARDS: I'm sorry, OK.
AUDIENCE: What are some
of the interventions--
I guess specifically, you
mentioned the foundation
that went to Cambridge.
And then I'm sure in your
development of insulin,
that you had opportunities
or things that
unlocked that ability for you.
DAVID EDWARDS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so I
was just wondering,
without getting too much into
the weeds of policy, what
are specific things you've seen
besides what you've already
mentioned that have worked
for people who maybe otherwise
would not have had
the opportunity?
DAVID EDWARDS: Well, let
me say that in my case--
and again, I write
about it in the book,
and I also point this out
in other creator lives--
I have found that in pursuing
my dreams to the extent
that my dreams matter
more than just to me,
I have very frequently
come to the edge
where, my god, this could be it.
And I always found someone
who came and helped.
And this notion of
activator, which
obviously in the
Italian Renaissance,
there are some
really famous ones.
But they're
everywhere right now.
And one of the great joys
of my own creative life
is the discovery
that I'm not alone,
and that there's this network.
And so in the inhaled insulin
case, I was a theoretical guy.
I'd written a
couple of textbooks
that five people in the
world had read, and published
this article.
And I had a series of people, a
venture capitalist I mentioned
who was more than a venture
capitalist who played
a really big role in my life.
But many, many,
many, many people.
So is there a recipe?
I don't know.
I have lived for
many years in Paris,
and have had lots
of conversations
with the French government,
and academia in France about,
how do we create
Harvard in Paris?
Is it an endowment?
Is that what we need?
And so my big point-- and maybe
this is the most concrete thing
I can say--
there's an amazing education
in France in many ways,
and really such bright people,
and such a rich culture.
But one thing that does not
thrive there, speaking really
generally, is as a student,
when I leave the university,
there's not a possibility
to take a big risk
and do really, really
well really quickly.
It's more of a climb the
ladder kind of phenomenon.
And I think that the creating of
opportunities for the dreamers
is the most important thing
that we can possibly do.
And I think it is a
challenge for big successful
organizations to create
those, because it's
hard to measure the value
of the little experiment
in the context of
the big, big mission.
But that's betting.
And maybe I'll
finish by just saying
that I was just in Atlanta
speaking to some people,
and the question was, well,
what can we most do to our kids,
and to help them create a world
that they want to live in,
and create what matters?
And my point to them again, it's
the point I make in the book--
is that the best thing we
can do, I think, to our kids
is help them see
that they matter.
And so I think that
you can't create
anything that matters if you
don't feel you matter first.
And so that, mattering for
me has generally been people
from my dad to lots of people,
my wife, lots of people
who've bet on me in a certain
way and said, you matter.
And so that's the easy answer.
AUDIENCE: What does
it mean to matter?
DAVID EDWARDS: What
does it mean to matter?
Well, as I say a little bit,
and I say more in the book,
almost anything
matters at some moment.
A raindrop matters that
some moment, right, and so
everything matters.
So it's a provocation.
But what it means in
the title of my book,
these are things that matter
not just to you, but to many,
and for a long period of time.
And so a way to translate that--
even that, if you dig
into it is kind of--
but they matter so much that
people want them to endure,
and so they will
help them endure.
It's like what you want of your
kid when your kid leaves home.
You want the kid to thrive.
And that's not just your girl
being really entrepreneurial,
but people wanting her, people
wanting her in the room.
And so creating
something that matters
is creating something
that's alive
and that has a right to live.
[APPLAUSE]